unas declaraciones que se dieron en el
marco de una conferencia de alto nivel
que
organizó el presidente de la cope en ti
6 allows arma en la que pidió que
necesitaba sus soluciones pragmáticas
para poder cerrar esta conferencia de
manera exitosa como bien lo decías de
john kerry hizo referencia a que es el
lenguaje tenía que permanecer tenía que
ser fuerte aprobó el lenguaje hablando
de adaptación mitigación y también y
contradiciéndose un poco en este mensaje
acerca de los combustibles fósiles dijo
que aprobaba este lenguaje que había
ahora en la nueva en el nuevo borrador
hablando de subsidios ineficientes y del
progresivo desaparición del carbón pero
también por otro lado dijo que los
subsidios tenían que desaparecer y que
el hecho de que estemos inyectando
billones de dólares cada año a estos
subsidios es la definición y lo digo
textualmente de
la unión europea también participó en
este en esta conferencia dijo que no es
algo político ya sino que es personal
frans timmermans que hablaba por la
unión europea habló de su nieto de un
año que dentro de 30 tendrá 31 años y
que bueno que va a sufrir las
consecuencias uno de los países más
críticos al actual boceto fue arabia
saudita hablando en representación del
grupo de países árabes que dijo que el
texto se está alejando demasiado de lo
que se había acordado en parís en 2015
recordemos que el acuerdo de parís no
hace ninguna mención concreta a los
combustibles fósiles y obviamente pues
arabia saudita es uno de los países
grandes productores de petróleo las
islas y países insulares pequeños todos
recalcaron que los efectos los están
existiendo sintiendo ya y que hay que
actuar y que los subsidios al petróleo
nos están destruyendo a todos parece que
se espera de este acuerdo final es
posible que sí se logre una aprobación
con el lenguaje que se está pidiendo en
estos momentos
pues las cifras no encajan con el
lenguaje que hay ahora mismo todo apunta
a que solo vamos a recortar en un 9%
perdón a acercarnos en un 9% a esa
temperatura al límite del grado y medio
centígrados para finales de siglo y sólo
quedan menos de dos horas para el final
oficial de esta con 26 un documento que
tiene que ser firmado por las 197 partes
y todo apunta a que las negociaciones se
van a alargar hasta mañana porque como
veíamos y como escuchábamos en esa
conferencia hay muchísimos puntos
todavía en los que no se ponen de
acuerdo sin embargo y nosotros tenemos
el pabellón de reino unido a unos pocos
metros de nosotros la música está
sonando a todo volumen pareciera como si
reino unido ya estuviera celebrando un
texto que todavía no está aprobado y que
parece que todavía faltan muchas horas
para que eso sea una realidad